welcome back to the TW LCQ live from
Bangkok Thailand I'm mark man I'm here
with rip spaghetti rip and Majin Obama
and we are about to start our top eight
tom mate time my oh my god LCQ HAP's
really really good diversity this topic
as well I think we're still having a
couple matches downstairs just to you
know figure out who's gonna be fully in
but man we have some killer matches
coming up man
oh yeah exactly we're gonna be starting
off with Korea versus Tyler
oh yeah you are you John dick going up
against talent who he's gonna be our
first match here winner sighs back at
jalan dig finally make it to atop a book
playing I was mine sending a tee but to
the loser's bracket mm-hmm and we
started the day talking about this too
right these are two players who weren't
used to seeing on taking world tour
especially in the finals right yeah and
traditionally the matchup has been 80 vs
jin but you know that's not a batch of
that I think favors Eddie at all
yeah because Jim has like a really if
you think about the 2d matchup
yeah Jin has like dwarfed if he's like a
walking 5050 basically you just look yes
if you want to go do what to wait for
any black plays man like just that he'll
suite four for three yet it's a it works
man especially with Eddie could not
being able to sidestep as well it's just
tough like you said yeah it's he's
forced to eat the mix-ups right yeah but
we'll see I mean is is he even gonna
pick Eddie in the matchup that's the
question he's hovering over him right
now I think you will man yeah a lot of
the players you today they pissed this
time you know they're thinking to their
main you know they're finally bringing
out the character loyalty who's like
alright fine everything else failed me
all year long I hope they'll takiyama
stick to my guns down you know rock
might even be no great matter Brian you
know it's working out for you and won
the party stage here as well for garden
realm
John ding vs. book Eddie versus Jin
Korea vs. Thailand
all right opening match here winners
side topping there's gonna be a race to
to wonder if this will move on to our
winners finals for the top eight
guarantees at least bad but it doesn't
matter man third and second ain't gonna
cut it you need that first-place win you
gotta win if you want to play on Sunday
you gotta win Wow interrupting him after
you try to advance after down back
warning will you take the floor from him
to return 50% yeah that helped a big
amount of hurt there's double power
crush there to end it okay books
starting to fight back you have to be
careful though it is so hard to beat
John thing when he has a live feed but
when he gets the life he just chills and
he just says okay like you gotta play my
game now so they're books and have to
try and get the early life if you wants
to win this just does it oh my god
he's already things are missing
knowledge getting started yeah that'd be
disrespecting the frames the advantage
that from Brooke just jabbing boots
worktop for everything right now going
down this way yeah launched again off
the wall be able to still get another
four he took every fourth yeah and look
at the positioning here good timing
I can't suck it deepest bull yeah I know
what it is but he has some kind of read
a book right now
yeah but look good dunk against the wall
Danny - here we go here comes his birth
combo this say candy get something stuff
that can he get around in the boat he's
playing so well today
yeah where was this guy this guy we've
seen this is the best we've seen him
play a full season look at this suit so
confident in the way he is facing away
from his opponent yeah they'll let big
10 seconds wall right they're not gonna
use the race oh nice
[Music]
because they definitely have mathy us
the LCQ and this top pay final round
their first game just does it
corner time now corner pressure hand for
John thing he waited to he wanted the
next show you got the relax bone tree
the follow-up he's raised drive
available yeah they just get another one
wanna come back reverse sweep heads high
lads
book the hometown hero
there we go chair to the crowd that was
absolutely crazy but this is like Mark
said this is for a spot in that winners
final great it's gonna be first two
three this is definitely read book wants
to be
the juggling has time and time again got
those cutbacks and we've seen it so many
times before the clutch factor this guy
has and many people might have seen it
but he's had so many games off stream
which I've been so clutch when he brings
back ready brings it back with a massive
thigh deficit John he was definitely
able to bring this back on what changed
in that last game Johnny had that big
lead wooded book to different I don't
that switch around I feel like he was
able to just get the live feed a bit
more you know and when he were when he
when he got that he didn't he wasn't
pushed to actually like be aggressive or
something you know because he got hit by
a lot of sites if there's three plus
four early on and then yeah so once you
got the laughs need I mean book was able
to be bit more calm that's why I think
most take a look here comes game to go
to suit this time sticking it out with
eddy gordo board for is connecting yet
yeah but he's trying real hard to make a
fort I need to know that he's looking to
sidestep anyways dude you keep throwing
out that's a great point nice low prayer
from John Dean don't you come to school
attack okay nice
now back for the folks yeah I see if we
get the punish here let's see what he
does
yeah I'm not gonna do a lot of damage
but he's gonna take him to the wall
wanting to be a port nope oh nice knew
he was gonna stay with the floor dad
didn't want to back focus Jonathan was
scared of getting hit by back to you but
either way what guess is right
Oh punished it could've been a little
bit more people more prepared for it did
you see this the patient's way but I can
Cornish gonna get the wallets reward yep
season three baby have you go and 50%
damn it just like that
yeah look who's feeling confident right
now
hair let's the wall right now do you
right now book doesn't have to do
anything he does have to take the
initiative to go in and he's still going
in so he's just so confident she wants
to finish it but he does have the life
let's see what he does oh you see that
down back to again oh wow and he dreams
with that one man that was huge he hit
the wall that might be it
nice a goal set for report to daughter
winners final yeah that's crazy
here in Thailand nice Johnny look right
now without fight though yeah I forgot
about the old Booker where were you
always that fit yeah top three P wins
this round you do that sweet fifth again
great with punished look at that adjust
the combo as well yeah beautiful
oh this is huge yeah cuz he has great oh
gosh so scary with the right punish but
he was too late John thing stays alive
yeah the hesitation and this is what
joining these cuz judging deftly needs
to tie it up yes still has a chance to
get it to winners final that was five
rounds straight for book and so John
dick finally got that round I mean these
are two guys that were just outside of
the qualification right
battling it out for this final spot only
one of these two paths Chen a nice
parrys coming out here for books uh-huh
very bad that is gonna hurt I think you
can't just about this this is pretty
nice blocks book still etiquette don't
close it out here click go final round
games you John they bring it back try to
get the reverse sweep to that book got
last match daddy oh yeah put it working
for 2 in Game one
science M People's War I've been getting
a ton of mileage out of it
what's the mix-up goes to the mid yeah
this time much mid oh my god the defense
of jotting holding up right now book
trying to find some opening closing it
out if we can get something trying to
steal back the light beam sighs
therefore gets blocked have you got book
now stolen the likely place a fragile
want the most trying to adding up on
both sides right now back to one oh just
out of range I'm gonna go be careful
that could have been used to book right
now though he does have a small likely
not enough to matter though still set
point half a book so much to play for
John big paint patiently oh just out of
age in the middle and get after all be
careful Lily gray might be trying to set
up here another size 2 3 4 situation but
the clock no-calorie time oh shoot
feels like he got it and book moving on
to our winners final here the hometown
hero crazy that's great yeah this is
crazy lost yet we had a European win DLC
cute in Europe are we gonna cap book
again brought a time that stuff was the
first thing I was thinking of like girl
on the last year he definitely got the
power from the crowd last yeah I mean it
made a huge difference
hmm that is craziness this is Chris but
Tekken is it's a good game it's a good
game I like it back or I'm down oh so
yeah that means that book will move Alan
jogging in the loser bracket